hello and welcome to see you playing
p.m. Scott Scott ok no name trying a new
sideline in the in the ROI Ernest III
okay interesting sooo what to do here
take it I absolutely have no idea i'm
kind of making up things in I what about
I wonder about g5g this is what I'm I
also has a turned maybe I can go be five
then yeah probably I can probably play
db5 d5 be five and then have light a
five on that before oh hmm I don't know
just experimenting a little bit with
this opening
yeah it looks good for him right not so
successful this experiment but I think
me this is still kind of okay should be
three I with a quick quick decision are
taking it looks looks wrong I don't know
see father is a very controversial
looking move let's do that but I'm not
not convinced I haven't every I don't
know okay he has to go D 45 now I think
otherwise I'll go in I go d5 and I'm
fine so he will go d5 and then I then I
was thinking f5 I have to have to be
aggressive him some who takes TX if it
takes to 7 mm no it doesn't okay
Knight takes Knight f5 and queen's eggs
i will also go night at five yeah we
gone either five maybe night each for
next or something like that can I tix if
he takes with a night I can they're
light xt5 I don't know it's got knight
c6 then right I was thinking night at
five and i'm going to i'm going to do
that okay probably won't hold take and i
won't take yeah and now queen to have
six blunders the Queen what I would like
to put more pressure on this if possible
maybe you just take and go push up at
five yeah come on the night on a five
and the bishop on a two they look like
they have the whole little kind of I
know standoff the eye on the queenside
really is really strange ok so what to
do him Knight f6 is super annoying and
here's the screen p6 move that it is
very much irritating if I move my queen
so let's do this at least you cannot
easily move the bishop you turn I'd be
three
Queen B 6 is no move unfortunately due
to Knight f6 check I think well yeah I
guess that's a very very difficult
position some endings could be good for
me for example but getting them getting
an ending in the first place might be
tricky hmm it looks like a good move
okay I'm going back and I try to get the
night to see 5 which also of course
might induce the bishop to move I don't
see 5 it's not that bad it covers e6 for
example which is important to do Oh
interesting very interesting move yeah I
would like to keep a protected pass of
it I don't think I need I need I need a
square here badly for that night night
on b7 is just an awful awful play
awfully an awfully place piece it is not
well placed let's raise it like that but
I think this should be quite ok now here
at night and it's a good good kind of
coordination here should be dangerous
for him rookie seven hours have rook f7
so going to get the porn roebling check
okay so looking after check but surprise
down the teasel did you trade stuff okay
um be aight i guess yeah i guess
politics okay so i can now take this and
get a root ending I think I rather
threaten this threaten this ending now
I'm threatening to take and play king 25
so he goes with this black in go King f5
and then King e four so this must be
good going for a full-scale invasion
if i take it I don't know if this is so
great actually King bee three kings
right okay let's take this I've got King
c5 mmm time money so how to do this this
is all protected f5 I still have under
control so this for okay 3i guess okay
45 check
I didn't play that well no not at all
this doesn't help when I didn't play
that well not at all
this should be okay again I cannot push
this Wow check check check check oh wait
for it yeah I was just realizing Oh blow
it was myself wow I have a better bet
ending play by the end game play I
should just win this with no hassle but
I didn't manage to it was a tricky game
choking him Jam him ok I think c4 is
probably what I have to do d5 and no f5
I'm surprised and computer thinks I'm a
lot better here hmm surprised I mean now
it evaluation gets down a bit it wants
to play Queen to be six and then just
take on d5 yeah ok maybe maybe you can
do that I didn't feel so ambitious sim
yeah well the computer is certainly
right herring if I can take it I mean
I'm happy too that was an important pawn
oh yeah I probably I didn't didn't see
that one I just I was just happy to
complete development and kind of kind of
be ok yeah before is the debatable move
but well this is kind of forced I guess
and now this ending must be good for me
I because i have this two against one on
the queenside and she doesn't have much
much counter pleasure however I really
played this ending
then I'm kind of okay you up to this
point I think this this takes it this
and now I have to play better here a
king f8 is strong Eric evade is strong
we're taking this and then I get this is
a probably not the best possible way i
can take h3 now maybe I should do that
now this is not ideal I still think it
should be ok and the computer says I'm
winning all the time check yeah maybe I
didn't play it so badly ok here now it
was was very much influenced by the so I
did by having no time they actually
blundered the rookie Edwin Abbott the
final move but I just I just added
moment I recognize that I'm down to
nothing myself ok thanks so much shape